[Música]
buscando una victoria putin mueve la
guerra de rusia hacia el este
funcionarios de inteligencia de eeuu
aseguran que algunas tropas rusas se
están retirando a belarús pero es poco
probable que regresen a casa
rusia está reposicionando sus fuerzas
para concentrar sus operaciones
ofensivas en el este y partes del sur de
ucrania en el este de ucrania
anticipamos que los comandantes rusos
están ahora ejecutando su red despliegue
desde el norte de ucrania la región
alrededor del donbass al no conseguir un
triunfo rápido en la capital ucraniana
kiev obtener el control de la región del
donbass en el este de ucrania es
fundamental para el presidente ruso
vladimir putin la zona incluye las
regiones separatistas respaldadas por
rusia donges y logan's las que se espera
que las tropas rusas tengan como próximo
objetivo los funcionarios de la zona
están instando a los ciudadanos a salir
inmediatamente por temor a un ataque
inminente ya
yo hablando de esto al menos tres
semanas la gente tiene que abandonar la
región para que las fuerzas armadas de
ucrania puedan actuar con mayor eficacia
y proteger la región de donges y ucrania
en su conjunto
en otra parte de la región de donges que
rusia ha avanzado sobre la estratégica
ciudad portuaria del sureste mariupol
que a pesar de los fuertes bombardeos y
los intensos combates callejeros no ha
logrado capturar una derrota frustrante
ya que la importante ciudad
proporcionaría a putin un corredor desde
10 a crimea la retirada de las fuerzas
rusas en torno a la capital de ucrania
supone una importante derrota para el
ejército ruso que pierde terreno en el
norte del país pero siguen realizando
pequeños y constantes avances
territoriales en el este por el objetivo
de aislar al ejército ucraniano